award-winning author Michael Ruhlman has
been writing about food for 20 years
he's collaborated with professional
chefs on cookbooks and written about the
basics of cooking in his new book
grocery the buying and selling of food
in America Ruhlman examines how the
supermarket and our relationship with
food have evolved since the early
neighborhood grocers it's a critical
look at the products we buy and how they
get on store shelves Michael Ruhlman is
with us now good morning morning great
to have you here I mean think about the
650 billion dollars we spend a year at
supermarkets how our grocery store is
essentially a reflection of our culture
they show us what we're afraid of what
our concerns are we know we're more
concerned about food than ever because
we're getting sick our food is making us
sick and we want to know how to feel
better and we think we can find that at
the grocery store and you say breakfast
is the most dangerous meal of the day I
consider it the most dangerous man our
breakfast is are composed of refined
wheat mainly in cereal cereals with
Gustin materials you have in your
greenroom our toilets are almost half
sugar even the ones without sugar are
refined wheat refined wheat is
essentially another carbohydrate that
becomes sugar in your bloodstream we eat
them on an empty stomach we eat
nutritionally bankrupt foods in the
morning and we should jump General Mills
said quote many of our cereals are
fortified with important vitamins and
minerals and all include large
quantities of whole grain why do we need
to fortify them in the first place
because we've taken everything
nutritional out of them so four to five
makes stronger I think it's a word that
you need to avoid rather than embrace no
you called breakfast cereals the
underground threat humming endlessly
like missiles I read that as I was
eating honey nut cheerios with raisins
and bananas yeah that's why I said
you're a little judging I also said this
you're in the supermarket line there's a
woman who's buying fat-free products or
something after you half-and-half yes
and you confronted her I wanted to talk
about that exchange and you say this 85%
of all American shop at the grocery
store 46 percent at super centers and 15
percent of unfortunates shop at
drugstores I was at CVS buying raisin so
I thought this guy is very judgy well
you have to be judgmental because no
one's talking cents I want people to
think about
food yes the woman but fat-free half an
ash looked like a responsible
intelligent woman I had to know why
would somebody buy fat-free half an F
when half an F is defined by the
quantity of fat in it I asked her what
you think what you think they're
replacing the fat with she looked look
at you and then looked at the label no
dummy she she said skim milk corn said
so they've removed the companies removed
what's good for us which is dairy fat
good wholesome dairy fat and replace it
what we know is bad for us sugar but I
like what you said about reading the
labels read the labels and you said if
you can buy everything on the label in
the grocery store then it's real food
it's real food if it tells you on the
package that it's food it probably isn't
remember that as well read the
ingredients read how much sugar is in it
and read the portion size if it's 25%
sugar and a serving size of 50 grams
that's half sugar so what should you do
in breakfast I like soaked whole-grain
steel cut oats with some yogurt some
nuts and raisins and egg is a great egg
and piece of cheese a lovely breakfast
so there's so many more food - yeah
we're always baking always stable okay
with bacon I love bacon you don't want
to be bacon all the time Charlie if you
ate lettuce all the time you get sick so
should we be careful of lettuce no
nobody you talked about the number of
food like eggs small medium and large
nice to be back in the day now there's
how many 15 different kinds of 40
different kinds of Oreos yeah that's not
good you saying well we're overwhelmed
by choice is the food manufacturers the
food producers found that they could
only crease our bottom line by creating
more products more varieties this is why
we have whole aisles devoted to salad
dressings but nor actually knows how to
cook well I do I mean I made I made
chicken thighs for my kids last night it
was really easy and it's like about the
easiest thing in the world to cook look
yeah but people are cooking less at home
and this is lending itself to a lot of
health problems right is we need to cook
more we need to ice we need to isolate
time to cook we don't say oh I'd love to
cook when I'm too busy you don't say I'd
love to shower I just don't of it thank
you so much Michael yeah really
yep the name of the book is called
grocery wherever you like to buy your
books it's got a lot of interesting
nuggets in you thank you - dude that is
a smirk I think